[Musik]
grüne herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video immer wieder waren musik wieder
mitgemacht wird diesmal was muss ich
wieder von guten denn natürlich muss
zugeben da war es nicht so
ausschlaggebend wie in den anderen
beiden musikvideos zu denen ich schon
mal so ein ähnliches video gemacht habe
dieses video ist auch genauso geil
eigentlich ohne meine effekte gewesen
und ich werde auch noch genommen mit
dieser technik also mit diesem skript
effekt wieder so ein bisschen das
musikvideo auf dem arm nehmen das heißt
ich werde einfach so rein krätzl in das
musikvideo aber nicht so wie ich es
gemacht habe um das muss ich wieder ein
bisschen cooler zu machen sondern so
ähnlich wie wenn jetzt jemand in der
zeitung ein kürzel und schnurrbärte und
was muss ich irgendwelche komischen
frisuren reinmacht genauso werde ich das
auch bei den machen aber jetzt zeige ich
euch erstmal was ich eigentlich war die
musik gemacht haben genau dieses weiße
drittel ist das habe ich doch
das ganze war tatsächlich ziemlich
aufwendig und ihr denkt euch jetzt
bestimmt harry hat er denn das mit einer
maus gemacht habe ich natürlich nicht
mit anderes gemacht das ganze mit einem
sogenannten grafiktablett gemacht da ist
einfach so ein brett und da kann man
jetzt mit einem elektronischen stift
drauf malen ich werde euch das
grafiktablett mal eine video
beschreibung vielleicht würde sich ja
jemand von euch angucken übel geile
track also ich finde ich richtig gut da
so richtig bösen flow einfach und passt
überall in diese rolle von grün schreien
dass ich selber ziemlich geil finden
sind diese zähne dir gerade seht im
hintergrund die die verleihen dem ganzen
aber noch so ein bisschen im bösen und
luft was einfach total geil dazu passt
wie ich finde hier gerade auch wenn wir
nochmal die flamme und die rakete von
timo boll und timo brauer die sich dann
extra noch mal gewünscht hat auf jeden
fall eine ultra geile idee von ihm jetzt
kann der tannenbaum und immer wenn er
sowas zeit komm raus hier auch hybrid
immer so umrandung hingezogen zeit sein
gesicht zu veranstalten ich denke ich
mal
aber davor machen wir es mal einen
schnauzer aufzuhübschen
hier noch ein kleines monokel ran und
man muss einfach sagen der typ hat jetzt
einfach viel mehr klasse und das mache
ich jetzt bild der welt für die
komplette szene fertig das hat jetzt
ungefähr 20 minuten geht arbeitet also
unglaublich langen wir gucken dass man
wie diamant mit klasse dann aussieht als
er ist eine unserer kurze clip aber mega
wird sich schon genau auf die gleiche
art und weise werde ich jetzt auch das
muss ich weitermachen was ich an sonst
noch so im video unterbringen könnte
seine piraten klappt schon her zu einer
christmas oder so was drauf oder eine
geile monopol was natürlich der
klassiker ist die stelle bietet sich da
jetzt perfekt an für eine coole harry
potter brille die steht doch dem guten
grund auf jeden fall perfekt so dass es
einmal was man kreis hier noch so ein
kreis sagt dann hier noch eine schicke
nach oben drauf unfähiges airport und
das mache jetzt wieder für ihn cool and
hot
das sehen wir gerade ausfallen hier so
wenn er sich also ich bin hätte ich so
langsam wird das video so wie es
wirklich so sollen spaß also hier
braucht auf jeden fall eine geile damit
seinen style wisst ihr ich muss einfach
zur geltung kommen als voraus sagt da
man so ein ding und effekte fliege alle
die an die märz komplett durch yaman
langsam wir das video vielleicht besser
er soll ja nicht so böse sein so wie er
alles noch ein bisschen bis er mir ist
alles in ordnung ist ihr da musste man
auf jeden fall noch einiges dran machen
so was könnte man hier machen ist er
überhaupt hier angeschnallt der ist hier
nicht mal angeschnallt also ihr könnt
man auf jeden fall einen guten pirat
ausmachen so die muss ja ganz ausgefüllt
zahlen dafür jetzt auf jeden fall noch
mit guten habe sonst ist es ja kein
echter pirat so als derart bestellen
sollte besser das einzige was jetzt noch
fehlt ist natürlich der klassiker so
nochmal an der stelle ich mir das
natürlich nicht als dies gegenüber der
energy der nach diesem mega korrekt und
ich bin mir sicher versteht dass ich
würde ja wohl ein bisschen spaß mit dem
filmmaterial des videos natürlich auch
ohne mann effekte und egal gewesen und
ich erlaube mir den spaß ein bisschen
drüber zu platzieren wie bei irgendeiner
zeit oder sowieso damit sind wir auch
fällig und ich denke wir konnten das um
einiges verbessern das musst du dir
nochmal hier sehen wir schon okay dann
hier die kleine hommage an leute die
hier nach harry potter
hier auf jeden fall liegt ihr alle flüge
unter dem piraten
ich hoffe dass wieder gefallen und
konnte vielleicht ein bisschen sogar was
lernt guckt euch auf jeden fall das
video von der natürlichen das in der
video beschreibung verlinkt checkt auch
mal bei mir beitritt schreien da werde
ich in zukunft regelmäßige stream wenn
ihr sehen wollt wie ich sowas ähnlich
ist auch schon mit dem musikvideo von
standard skill und reden gemacht hat
dann guckt in die beschreibung glaube
ich dass verlegt und wenn er mich auf
dieser reise begleiten wollte dass er
gern abo da und dann sehen was beim
nächsten video machen es gut
[Musik]